all right joining us now as we continue
on Hannity the author of the
best-selling book vengeance former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich you know you
have this incredible perspective because
I'm making an argument tonight that
thirty years of the Clintons and 30
years of smearing and slandering those
women now the reckoning of the Clintons
coming all right so they came on the
national scene in 1990 1991 and now the
Clintons can't do anything for the
Democrats anymore you know as I'm
looking at them as a party I'm saying
when is the day of reckoning she took
all this money from countries that
abused women kill gays and lesbians and
persecute Christians and Jews it it's
kind of insulting the ones intelligence
isn't it well okay I think we're at a
very important turning point for
American culture we've gone through a
long period what I described is the age
of the Kardashians where you could do
anything get away with anything there's
a fascinating book that contrasts the
independent council in Bill Clinton and
suggested actually that particular
investigation was when virtue died in
America well maybe what we begin to see
happen is virtue coming back in America
as people realized whether it's the
extraordinary scale of the opioid
epidemic which the Trump administration
reported on today or the stunning amount
of harassment and violation of women
that we're seeing come out day after day
now all of a sudden all these things
that the left tolerated
are beginning to be unacceptable and
very painful and that may lead the
country not just Republicans not just
concerns but the country they have a
really serious conversation about what
are the standards we want going forward
how do we ever ascertain truth he said
she said it becomes very difficult if
you believe in the presumption of
innocence well there are two different
things here first of all you do have a
tendency for hysteria and a lynch mob
attitude so anybody can say anything
about the last 40 years and there's an
automatic presumption of guilt that's
got to be washed away mean we've got to
go back to the principle you're innocent
until proven guilty and we've seen cases
you know the Duke University I think it
was was their lacrosse team cross it's
totally smeared and turned yeah it
turned out to be totally false they've
been a whole series these kind of cases
so I do think in that sense we got to go
back to the core principle that you are
innocent until proven guilty on the
other hand I also think you've got to
recognize that one of the purposes of
Congress is to undertake investigations
almost like a grand jury I mean the
things that are coming out now for
example about the whole uranium one case
and all the pieces that surround that
and I say to myself where's the
congressional hearing that week after
week month after month simply strips
away the lies and gets the facts back up
so the American people can sell would
really have the new development tonight
and know you've read this article is
that you've had an FBI informant in
there may have been there as long now as
six years we're discovering thousands of
pages of documents available and that in
fact they knew that Vladimir Putin had
purposely set out with agents involved
in criminal activity bribes extortion
money laundering kickbacks racketeering
that we had an informant that knew all
this was happening was reporting back to
the FBI and apparently it was even in
Obama's presidential daily briefing this
is before Cepheus ended up giving the
the nine department approval including
Hillary State and Eric Holder's justice
and allowed this deal to go through
which on the surface never made sent 20
that never made sense 20% of America's
uranium in the hands of a bad actor a
hostile regime Putin and Russia let me
say first of all they have done the most
thorough most systematic work on this
and if you take their work and that of
Peter Schweitzer who's written the book
Clinton cash between them they've done
more to educate the country than all the
congressional hearings all the stuff
being done at the Justice Department I
mean it is appalling
the the gap of serious responsible
investigation when they come up week
after week with more and more
and I think you've been frankly the
number one person helping them reach the
American people and without your support
of their work they would still be
basically totally unknown but they ought
to get a Pulitzer degrees for the level
of investigative research they're now
doing you know last question so the
president while he's in China gets these
four or three UCLA basketball players
out then the father of one of the kids
makes a statement that he didn't do much
now you steal in China even go to jail
for years and so the president says well
maybe I just should have left you there
and then I'm thinking that's pretty
ungrateful isn't it that the father if
it was my son I'd say sir thank you for
standing up for my father I'm gonna
handle whatever it was they did wrong
myself at home but thank you you know
this could have been a potential
disaster in his life now there are
people in the corrupt news media in this
country tonight that are saying what the
president tweeted his racism because he
basically said well maybe I should have
left him in jail well that nothing to do
with their race first of all I think
it's a sad commentary on what's happened
to America when a father being told that
his son was shoplifting in China he's in
really angry at his son I mean he ought
to be grateful to the president because
his son could have been in really deep
trouble and second if I mean if you're a
UCLA basketball player you're at a great
university I have a great future what
are you doing shoplifting I think the
people should be pretty irritated that
these guys who have a privileged life
have a privileged future have the chance
for a multi-million dollar career in the
NBA or out here you know embarrassing
America looking stupid and doing
something that's totally dumb and I'm
embarrassed for that father that he
didn't have the decency to say thank you
mr. president I got to talk to my kid
here I clearly didn't quite certainly
get things across to him I just think
this is a sign of what's sick about
America the people don't take
responsibility they don't take
accountability
now probably Trump shouldna said I
should have left him in jail well you
ought to say is I wish that father had
been there in jail let the kids come
home it's the father a great thank you
not to kill it simple just thank you sir
for what you did for my son I'll take
care of this the stupidity of what he
might have been involved in simple
alright mr. speaker there to see you
thank you for being less